Bruno Mars is back with new music and a  brand new partnership with MGM Resorts  we're trying to party with you Bruno the  31 year old singer has linked up with  MGM for a series of upcoming  performances at two state-of-the-art  venues  first up the theater at MGM National  Harbor in Maryland Bruno will host a  special engagement on December 27 where  he'll be one of their first performers  ever  the entertainer is also heading to Sin  City he'll help kick off the new year  with performances on December 30th and  31st at the brand-new Park Theatre at  the Monte Carlo Resort and Casino  he's also slated to return for more  concerts in Vegas in March 2017